-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
We're hanging out
with Hasan Minhaj.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Hello. Yes.
-Now, we're about to play
"Hey Robot."
Here we go.
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, robot ♪
♪ Hey, robot ♪
Now, here's how it works.
This is based on a real
board game, Hey Robot,
that you can play at home.
It's like the classic game
Password,
but your partner is
a smart speaker, okay?
Now, first, what you do is you
pick a card with a word on it,
then we'll take turns
asking a question
to get the speaker to say that
word somewhere in its answer.
If it does, you get a point.
Ready for this?
-Got it, yes.
-I will go first.
Alright, here we go.
Unmute it.
Okay, here's the word I have
to get it to say.
Alright.
Alexa, what is
Morris Day's band?
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
According to wikipedia.org,
Morris Day is best known
as the lead singer of The Time.
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Okay. Okay.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
-Sorry, man, you know.
-Alright. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Okay.
-You know what I'm saying, dude?
-Okay.
[ Cheering ]
Okay. Okay.
-You know what I'm saying, dude?
You know what I'm saying, dude?
-I'm not going to twerk.
I'm not going to twerk.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not going to twerk, alright?
These smediums are too tight,
you know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
-"Smediums."
-Yeah, you know.
-Hasan, here's your word
right there.
-Okay.
-No, you --
-I got to flip it?
-Yeah, you flip it.
You can show everyone.
Tell everyone.
-Okay.
-Mutant.
-Got it.
-Yeah, I think you've got this.
-Okay.
-Yep.
-Alexa,
Wolverine in "The X-Men"
[ Laughter ]
is a blank.
-Wolverine is featured
in "X-Men" with Hugh Jackman.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Wait, what were you saying?
-Wolverine.
-Do it again.
-Okay. Alexa,
in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, the X-Men are...?
-Marvel Cinematic Universe's
sections are
"Captain America: Civil War,"
"Ant-Man," -"Iron Man 3"...
-Jimmy, you get this?
-"Iron Man," "Iron Man 2."
-Alexa, I'm about to replace you
with Google Home.
[ Laughter ]
Like you keep acting up.
-Sorry.
I'm having trouble hearing.
[ Laughter ]
Can you say that again?
-Alexa, stop. Here we go.
-Alexa, stop it.
-We need this one.
Alright.
♪♪
Alexa, stop.
Alright -- Stop.
[ Laughter ]
Alright. We need mutant.
Alexa, what are Ninja Turtles?
-According to Wikipedia,
Teenage Mutant Ninja --
[ Bell dings ]
-No!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ The Roots play funk ]
♪♪
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
I didn't have any bills.
-You understand the game now?
Okay, Alexa, stop.
Alexa, stop.
Alright, here we go.
Okay. Alright.
-My turn. Sure, sure, sure.
-You take this one, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Alexa, when you hit someone,
you give it a...?
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
According to wikipedia.org,
it means to strike someone
or something.
Did that answer your question?
-No!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Buzzer ]
-What are you talking about?
Fill in the blank,
you're playing with Alexa?
You can't play
Fill in the Blank.
-Okay. Okay. So.
-What's he talking about?
[ Laughter ]
It's not a real thing.
-Alright.
How do I work backwards?
Now I have to do algebra, right?
X equals whack like.
[ Laughter ]
Alright. Okay, Jimmy, go.
Go, go.
You're friends with Alexa.
You're in cahoots.
[ Laughter ]
Alexa, name some
of Howard Stern's costars.
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
According to thethings.com,
"Howard Stern Show fans
have fallen in love
with Ben and Ray Stern
ever since the earliest days
of Howard's incredible career.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Buzzer ]
-There you go.
-I thought the Wack Pack.
-Yeah.
-Whack.
Oh.
-Can we do that thing like when
you're playing with your family,
just skip it.
Can we skip?
-We can skip it or we can go.
Wait. Let's try it again.
-No, no, no, go, go ahead.
-Let's solve it.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Because I'm trying to go
"What is whack?"
You know what I mean?
What is whack
and what would make --
-Alexa, read the poem
"Knick Knack Paddy."
-Oh!
-I couldn't find
"Knick Knack Paddy."
[ Audience ohs ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Yeah, you could.
[ Sad trombone, rimshot ]
You could, actually.
-Alexa, you totally could.
-It's very easy.
-Alexa, are you spying on us
all the time?
[ Smattering of laughter ]
-There you go.
-Oh, right.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, we're passing.
We're passing. We're passing.
-Let's pass.
-Alright, we're going to go
this is the final round.
-Final round?
-Hasan, I want you to try
to get this. Here we go.
-Sure. Sure.
This is like
all the bonus points.
-Yeah.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Ohs and cheering ]
-Okay.
Okay.
Alexa...
...a movie with Mark Wahlberg
where he plays a stripper.
-Hmm. I don't know that one.
-No, no, Alexa, a movie --
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪
No, no, no, no!
Quest, don't do that.
Don't do that.
I know you're a cinephile.
Alexa, Alexa, the movie where
Mark Wahlberg...
-Do you have --
-...where he plays a porn star.
-The only John Martin movie is
"Gettysburg:
Three Days of Destiny."
-Wait, stop.
[ Buzzer ]
Alright, do it again,
do it again.
-Okay, okay.
-Try it again, try it again.
-Alexa, movie with
Mark Wahlberg where he plays --
-I know about 137 Mark Wahlberg
movies, including...
-Wait a minute. 137 movies.
-You know 137, and you're gonna
go through all of them.
-They're going to go through
all of his movies.
Alexa, what are the lyrics to --
Alexa, what are the lyrics to
"I Love the Nightlife"?
-Here's something
I found on the web.
According to wikipedia.org,
"I Love the Nightlife
(Disco 'Round)"
is a popular disco song
recorded by American singer
Alicia Bridges in 1978.
[ Buzzer ]
-Come on.
Alright, you got another one?
-Okay.
-Can we crack this?
-We got to crack this.
Okay.
-But, first -- Oh.
-No, no, no. Quest, what's up?
-The first single from
The Jacksons' "Destiny" album.
-Okay.
-Wow!
-Alexa, what's
the first single off
The Jacksons' "Destiny" album?
-Here's something
I found on the web.
According to wikipedia.org,
despite the Mick Jackson
original reaching
a number 61 peak
on the Billboard Hot 100
in September 1978, Epic Records
that month released
The Jacksons' version
of "Blame It on the Boogie..."
-Yes!
-Oh, my God!
♪♪
-Yeah!
-Wow!
-[ Laughs ]
-Yo!
-Who was that? Me?
-That was you, man!
-That was you. Oh, my God.
-I'm sweating.
I'm sweating. I love you, dude.
We're friends forever.
-Yeah, forever.
-Hasan Minhaj, everybody.
Catch him on tour
with his new stand-up show,
"The King's Jester."